guys guys it's happening
we're finally getting we're finally
getting folding smartphones but like but
why though hey what's up guys I'm Kim
PhD here so folding smartphones are
slowly becoming a thing more and more
real couple months ago they wore
anything now they are here's the
timeline so for the past couple of
months or weeks there have been sort of
murmurings of a foldable phone but
nothing actually coming to reality we'd
seen flexible OLED displays in the past
and things that weren't really
functional devices but nothing had come
to reality yet then a couple of days ago
probably just to beat Samsung with a
punch to say that they were first a
pretty unknown company called Royale
corporation unveiled a smartphone called
the flex PI
so the Royale flex PI the world's first
flexible smartphone and without actually
trying it and getting hands-on myself
just judging from this hands-on footage
this is roughly speaking the ugliest
thing I have ever seen
it barely actually folds it's kind of
more of just a bend in the middle and
there's a lot of leftover screen in the
middle that doesn't fold it looks
uncomfortable to hold and the actual
folding and unfolding process is
absolutely brutal though graphics are
flickering you kind of have to feel like
you're almost breaking the phone it's a
lot it's whatever it's early though I
get it so made this appearance and the
only other info we got were the price
and the storage it's gonna be $1300 for
the hundred twenty eight gig version to
start whenever it comes out by the way
we don't know when it is supposed to
come out or if it will actually happen
but that's what we've been told but the
more familiar story is around the same
time samsung had been sort of teasing
that they're going to unveil their
flexible smartphone there were the
beginnings of leaks but not really much
for a day they changed their profile
picture to a a bent Samsung logo which
they changed it back the next day but
it's just kind of clever marketing and
trolling at the same time they're gonna
do something and then it finally
happened
so yesterday on stage at the developer
conference Samsung unveiled
their version of a flexible smartphone
it's called the Infinity flex display it
folds the other way inward and it was
shown on stage like this after they
dimmed the lights opening and closing
from a tablet size to a phone size
already looking better than that flex
pay nice okay pause so this by itself
this is dope tech I like this I think
this is cool the fact that we can get to
this level of advanced smart phones and
flexible OLED to the fact that we can
make an entire device that folds in half
like this that's really cool but why
would we want to have that every day
what I would I want to fold and unfold
my smartphone into a tablet every single
day we're not supposed to think about
that yet there is a reason it went dark
in there
this is very unfinished Samsung said the
actual phone is coming hopefully next
year in 2019 and even when it does if it
does its first generation stuff so I
wouldn't expect anything too radically
polished around the same time we also
did get Google announcing Android is
going to support folding displays
natively so that should help smooth some
things over especially in the graphics
department but what we were looking at
on stage was not some finalized
completed folding phone you can buy some
time soon it was a working prototype of
a flexible device that can hopefully be
turned into something they can
manufacture by sometime next year
here's a clearer look from Chris Welch
average reporter who apparently got
video during a rehearsal from Samsung
where they left the lights on and right
there you can see the gigantic bezels
and the rest of the device pretty
clearly including a crease down the
middle where it folds Samsung onstage
said it's in this sort of case to hide
the final design but we can be pretty
sure they don't have a final design yet
now what Samsung is aiming for can be
found in some diagrams later in
Samsung's presentation and you can see
it still has some top and bottom bezels
which will be pretty thick the overall
entire device will also be pretty thick
I guess it's got to be twice the size of
a normal smartphone from top to bottom
but still somewhat interesting that it's
foldable we got some specs from Samsung
too so they plan for the folded up phone
size that they're aiming for it to be a
four point six inch display 1960 by 840
and then when it's
folded the tablet size would be 7.3
inches at 21 52 by 1536 so here's what
I'm hoping this is obviously very
generation one and it's of a prototype
of a device that may or may not be
coming in its final version in 2019 I'm
hoping this whole foldable thing is the
beginning of what could turn into a much
more important much more interesting
compelling form factor way down the line
in the future it's reminiscent of think
of the bezel intend phones now right now
we're pretty much all trying to get
these bezels phones by shrinking down
the chin and the top notch as much as
possible right before that it was
spinning out the side bezels by getting
it as close to the left and right edge
as possible we pretty much got as close
as we need to now but a major part of
that started in 2014 when phones all
kind of had somewhat thicker side
vessels and Samsung took a weird step
and introduced a crazy product the
project was the Samsung Galaxy Note edge
which had a part of the display on one
side curving over the edge with this
glass and the bleeding edge look they
tossed a couple sliding apps on one side
gave it a few features and sold it it
seemed kind of weird and kind of maybe
useless but it caught on and then the
next year the note had a display
bleeding over both sides and soon enough
every Samsung phone had an infinity
display with the whole bezel estate that
just kept going and going so it might
not look significant at first and the
generation 1 version might not be that
compelling at all we don't know how it
feels on the hand or in the pocket or
how easy it is to fold or what the apps
do on each side we don't we don't know
any of that but if we give it some time
to evolve and find out where it's useful
and then iterate on that it could turn
out to be great so I applaud you Samsung
I thank you for trying the crazy stuff
Samsung's in one of those positions
where they can just try crazy stuff with
screens that's kind of their thing
they're so good at displays now but they
can dedicate a team to try and crazy
stuff like the infinity edge display or
folding o LEDs and just see if it
catches on so maybe just maybe this one
will we'll see
anyway back to the reviews thanks for
watching this one talk to guys later
peace
technically Apple had the first folding
phone with the iPhone 6s plus weird flex
but okay